Jenkins is the PowerHouse behind modern
software development streamlining the
entire build and deployment process in
this comprehensive course we will unlock
the potential of Jenkins teaching you
how to automate tasks integrate diverse
tools and orchestrate the software
delivery pipeline like a pro from
setting up Jenkins pipelines to managing
configurations and scaling for large
projects we will cover it all whether
you are a seasoned developer looking to
boost productivity or a beginner you get
to dive into devops then this course
will Empower you to harness the full
potential of Champions for efficient and
error-free software development if these
are the type of videos you'd like to
watch then hit that subscribe button and
the bell icon to get notified when we
host as we speak you might wonder what
it takes to become an expert devops
engineer if you are a professional with
at least one year domain experience and
is looking for online training and
certification from the prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more the
postgraduate program and devops by
Caltech University offered by simply
learn in collaboration with IBM should
be the right choice for you for more
details head straight to our homepage
and search for devops postgraduate
program or simply click on the link in
the description box below with that in
mind over to our training experts
Jenkins is a web application that is
written in Java and there are various
ways in which you can use and install
Jenkins I have listed popular three
mechanisms in which Jenkins is usually
installed on in any system the topmost
one is as a Windows or a Linux Based
Services so if at all you have Windows
like the way I have and I'm going to use
this mechanism for this demo so I would
download a MSI installer that is
specific to Jenkins and install this
service so whenever installed as a
service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
Jenkins and I have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my name
any flavor of Linux as well one other
way of running Jenkins is downloading
this generic War file and as long as you
have jdk installed you can launch this
war file by the command opening up a
command prompt or shell prompt if it
earlier on Linux box specifying Java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using Jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a
control C and then bring down this
prompt and your Jenkins server would be
down other older versions of Jenkins
were run popularly using this way in
which you already have a Java based web
server running up and running so you
kind of drop in this war file into the
root folder or the httpd root folder of
your web server so Jenkins would explode
and kind of bring up your application
all user credentials or user
Administration is all taken care of by
the Apache or the Tomcat server or the
web server on which Jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they all already have a Java web server
which it's being nicely maintained and
backed up Jenkins can run attached to it
all right so either ways it doesn't
matter however you're going to bring up
your Jenkins instance the way we're
going to operate Jenkins is all going to
be very very same or similar one with
the subtle changes in terms of user
Administration if at all you're
launching it through any other web
server which will take care of the user
Administration otherwise all the
commands are all the configuration are
the way in which I'm going to run this
demo it is going to be same across any
of these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running Jenkins as I
mentioned earlier Jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that is run in
Java so all that it needs is Java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2GB Ram is the
recommended RAM for running Jenkins and
also like any other open source tool
sets when you install jdk ensure that
you set in the environment variable Java
home to point to the right directory
this is something very specific to jdk
but for any other open source tools that
you've installed there is always a
preferred environment variable that you
got to set in which is specific to that
particular tool that you're going to use
this is a generic thing that is there
for you know for any other open source
projects because the way open source
projects discover themselves is using
this environment variables so as a
general practice or a good practice
always set these environment variables
accordingly so I already have GDK 1.8
installed on my system but in case you
do not what I would recommend is just
navigate on your browser to the Oracle
home page and just type in or search for
install jdk1.8
and navigate to The Oracle home page you
will have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers that is okay that you can
pick up based upon the operating system
on which you're running so I have this
windows 64 installer that is already
installed and running on my system so I
will not be into the details of
downloading this or installing it let me
show you once I install this what I've
done with regard to my path
so if you get into environment variables
all right so I've just set in a Java
home variable
if you see this C colon program files
Java jdk 1.8 this is where my my Java is
located C program files C program files
Java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what I've been I've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my Java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that in case you want to run Java
or Java C from a command prompt and show
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere I will see yes there you go
SQL and program files Java jdk 1.8 pin
so with these two I'll ensure that my
Java installation is nice and you know
good enough so to check that to double
check that or to verify that let me just
open up a simple command prompt
and if I type in Java iPhone version
all right and Java C
yphen version
so the compiler is on the path Java is
on the path and if at all I do this
even the environment variable specific
to my Java is installed correctly so I
am good to go ahead with my Jenkins
installation
now that I have my prerequisites
all set for installing Jenkins let me
just go ahead and download Jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
Jenkins
all right LTS is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies I would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that long term support
is good enough and as I mentioned there
are so many flavors of Jenkins that is
available for download alright so what I
want is yes this is the war file with a
generic War file that I was talking to
you earlier and this is the windows MSI
installer so go ahead and download this
MSI installer I already have that
downloaded so let me just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
Jenkins instance or other installer this
is a pretty maybe a few months old but
this is good enough for me
before you start uh Jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called Jenkins home this is
where Jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs deposit
workspace and all that specific to
Jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an MSI
installer all your installation gets
into SQL and program files 86 and
Jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user ID with
which you're running your War file the
Jenkins folder there's a DOT Jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
Jenkins or you want Jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
Jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
I don't need to do any of this thing so
I've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation all right so this is my
Jenkins MSI installer I would just I
don't want to make any changes in into
the Jenkins configuration SQL and
program files is good for me yeah this
is where all my destination folder and
all the configuration specific to it
goes I'm happy with this I don't want to
change this I would just say go ahead
and click installation
okay so what typically happens once the
Jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done
so and by default Jenkins Launches on
the port 8080. so let me just open up
localhost 8080
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein I need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so I'll have to just copy this
path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a Jenkins installation so as a part of
the installation it just asks you to do
this
so if that is not correct it'll
about it but this looks good so it's
going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation so you would need to
install some recommended plugins what
happens is the plugins are all related
to each other so it's like the typical
RPM kind of a problem where you try to
install some plugin and it's got a
dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what Jenkins
recommends is a bunch of plugins that is
already recommended so just go ahead and
blindly click that install recommended
plugin so if you see there is a whole
lot of plugins which are bare essential
plugin that is required for Jenkins in
order to run properly so Jenkins as a
part of the installation would get all
these plugins and then install it for
you this is a good combination to kind
of begin with and mind you at this
moment Jenkins needs lots of bandwidth
in terms of network so in case your you
know your network is not so good few of
these plugins would kind of fail and
these plugins are all you know all
available on openly or or mirrored sites
and sometimes some of them may be down
so do not worry in case some of these
plugins kind of fail to install you'll
get an option to kind of retry
installing them but just ensure that you
know at least most or 1995 of all these
plugins are installed without any
problems let me pause the video here for
a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed my plugin
installation is all good there was no
failures in any of my plugins so after
that I get to create this first admin
user again this is one important point
that you got to remember
given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it alright so I'm going to create a very
very simple username and password
something that I can remember
I will
that's my name and an email ID is kind
of optional but it doesn't allow me to
go ahead in case I don't so I just given
an admin and I get a password I've got I
remember my password this is my full
name all right I say seven finish
all right that kind of completed my
Jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that I have my Jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
UI is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys but if at all you're a
Java guy you know how painful it is to
write UI in Java you would kind of
appreciate you know all the effort that
has gone into the UI bottom line UI is
little hard to you know wrap your head
around it but once you start using it
possibly you'll start liking it all
right so let me get into something
called as manage Jenkins
this can be viewed like a main menu for
all Jenkins configuration so I'll get
into some of those important ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete Jenkins instance few things to
kind of look out for this is a home
directory this is a Java home where all
the configurations all the workspace
anything and everything regarding
Jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's possibly show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets Jenkin know
at any point in time how many jobs or
how many threads can be run you can you
can kind of visualize it like a thread
that can be run on this particular
instance as a thumb rule if at all
you're on a single core system number of
executors two should be good enough in
case at any point in time if there are
multiple jobs that kind of get triggered
the same time in case the number of
executors are less compared to the
number of jobs that have that woken up
no need to panic because they will all
get queued up and eventually Jenkins
will get to running those jobs just bear
in mind that whenever a new job kind of
you know gets triggered the CPU usage
and the memory usage in terms of the
disk right is very high on the Jenkins
instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors two for my system is kind of
good label for my Jenkins I don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your Jenkins this is good
for me because I only have a primary uh
server that is running so I want to use
this node as much as possible quite
better each of these options I've got
some bare minimal help kind of a thing
that is that is out here by clicking on
these question marks you will get to
know as to what are these particular
configurations
all right so this all look good what I
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin SVN email
notifications I don't want that what I
want the yes I want this SMTP server
configuration remember I mentioned
earlier that I would Bond Jenkins to be
sending out some emails and what I've
done here is I've just configured the
SMTP details of my personal email ID
in case you are in a in an organization
you would have some sort of an email IDs
that is set up for a Jenkins server so
you can specify the SMTP server details
of your company so that you know you can
authorize Jenkins to kind of send out
emails but in case you want to try it
out like me I have configured my
personal email ID which is on my Gmail
for sending out notifications so the
SMTP server would be
smtp.gmail.com I'm using the SMTP
authentication I have provided my email
ID and my password I'm using the SMTP
Port which is 465 and I'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine I can
just send out an email and see if at all
this configuration works again Gmail
would not allow you to allow anybody to
send out notifications on your behalf so
you'll have to lower the security level
of your Gmail ID so that you can allow a
programmatically somebody to send out
email notifications on your behalf so
I've done already that I'm just trying
to see if I can send a test you email
with the configuration that I've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your you
know your Gmail account in case you want
to do that if not put in your
organization SMTP server details which
are for the valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that I'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so I come back to manage
inkins okay one other thing that I want
to kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine the scenario or look at it this
way Jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know what
kind of a code base it's going to pull
in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you would have to put in all
the tools that is required for building
the appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just give
you an example in case your source code
is a Java source code and assuming that
you know because in this a demo this is
my laptop and I've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because I'm a developer I am
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case I want
Jenkins to you know run a Java code I
would need to install GDK on it I need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since I already have the jdk
installed and I've already put in the
Java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly I don't
need to do it git if at all I want the
Jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command bash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
Gradle and Maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system which is your continuous
integration server you will have to come
in here and configure something
in case you don't configure it when
chenkins runs it will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it'll crib about it
that's good I don't want to save
anything
manage Jenkins let me see what else is
required yes configure Global Security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to Jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know Jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the usernames
which hashes up these usernames and kind
of stores them
so as of now it Jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad or an ldap server using
which you would want to control access
to your Jenkins repository rather
Jenkins tool so you would specify your
ldap server details the root DN password
or the manager DN and the manager
password and all these details in case
you want to connect your Jenkins
instance with your ldap or ad or any of
the authentication servers that you have
in your organization
but for now since I don't have any of
these things I'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so I will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once I put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that Jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have Jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so I'm going to save
all this stuff that's good for me so
enough of all these configurations let
me put in a very very simple job all
right so job new item you know little
difficult to kind of figure out but then
that's the new item so I will just say
you know first job this is good for me I
just give a name for my job I would say
it's a freestyle project that's good
enough for me I don't want to choose any
of that so unless until you choose any
of this this particular button would not
become active so choose the freestyle
project and say okay
at a very high level you will see
General source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you will see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am I doing at the
moment I'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so I don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo purpose let me just put in a very
very simple job I'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first Jenkins job all right I don't want
to choose any of these again there are
some helps available here
I don't want to choose any of this I
don't want to connect it into any source
code for now I don't want any triggers
for now I'll come back to this in in a
while build the environment I don't want
any build environment as a part of this
build step you know I just want to you
know run few things so that I kind of
complete this particular job so since
I'm on Windows box I would say execute
Windows batch command
all right so what do you want to do I
let me just Echo something Echo
uh hello this is my first Jenkins job
and possibly I would want the date and
the timestamp
pertaining to the job I mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right I don't want to do anything
else I want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me save this job
all right so once I save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then I need to build this job and you
would see some build history out here
nothing is there as of now because I've
just put in a job I have not run it yet
all right so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you will see a
date and a timestamp so if I click on
this you will see a console output if I
go here
okay as simple as that and where is all
the job details that is getting into if
you see this
if I navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
I was mentioning earlier regarding
Jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular Jenkins installation is all
here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here all right so the workspace is
where all the jobs that I've created
whichever I'm running would you know
there will be an individual folders
specific to the jobs that has been put
up here all right so one job one quick
run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
I would say second job
I would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
I just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on Jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what I said earlier about
Jenkins because at the core of Jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server all right so what I'm going to do
I will just keep everything else the
same I'm going to put in the build
script pretty much similar to
second job
that gets triggered
automatically
every minute all right let me do that
percentage date and I'll put in the time
all right so I just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what I was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time I'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger so a build can
be triggered using various triggers that
is there so we'll get into this GitHub
uh triggering our hook or a web hook
kind of a triggering later on but for
now what I want to do I want to ensure
that this job that I'm going to put in
would be automatically triggered on its
own let's say every minute I want this
job to be run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you you have written cron jobs
on Linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's one two three four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that I'm
gonna put in and Jenkins got a little
worried and she's asking me do you
really mean every minute oh yeah I want
to do this every minute let me save this
and how do I check whether it gets
triggered every minute or not I just
don't do anything I'll just wait for a
minute and if at all everything goes
well Jenkins would automatically trigger
my second job in a minute's time from
now
this time around I'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see it's
automatically got triggered
if I go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42 1642 which is 442 my time that
looks good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this job would be
automatically triggered
now that I have my Jenkins up and
running a few jobs that has been put up
here on my Jenkins instance I would need
a way of controlling access to my
Jenkins server this is wherein I would
use a plugin called role based access
plugin and create few rules the rules
are something like a global Rule and a
project role product specific growth I
can have different rules and I can have
users who have signed up or the users
who might create kind of assigned to
these roles so that each of these users
fall into some category this is my way
of kind of controlling access to my
Jenkins instance and ensuring that
people don't do something unwarranted
alright so first things first let me go
ahead and install a plugin for doing
that so I get into manage Jenkins and
manage plugin
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there's updates available
installed in advanced as of now we don't
have the role based plugin so let me go
to available it'll take some time for
you to get refreshed all right now these
are the available plugins these are the
install plugins all right so let me come
back to available and I would want to
search for my role based access plugin
so I would say search for role and hit
enter
okay role-based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a
role-based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or notes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that I want I would want to
install it without a restart
all right looks good so far yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember Jenkins is running on a Java
using a Java instance so typically many
things would work the same way
understand until you want to restart
Jenkins once in a while but as a good
practice whenever you do some sort of
big installations or big patches on your
Jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restarted otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your Jenkins instance but for
now I don't need that it looks good I've
installed the plugin so where do you see
my plugin I install the plugin that is
specific to the user control or the
access control so let me go into yes
Global Security
and I would see this role-based strategy
showing up now all right so this comes
in because of my installation of my role
based plugin so this is what I would
want to enable
because I already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what I'm going
to install I mean I've already installed
a role-based strategy plugin and I'm
going to enable that strategy all right
I would say save okay now I have
installed the role based access plugin I
would need to just set it up and check
that you know I would go ahead and
create some roles and ensure that I
assign users as per these roles all
right so let me go to
manage Jenkins
configure all right let me see where is
this configure configure Global Security
is that where I create my rules
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now I have just enabled the plugin I
have enabled role based access control
and I would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular Jenkins
instance so I would say first manage
rules
so I would need to create some roles
here and the roles are at a very high
level these are Global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules I'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a row a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so I would
create a role called developer typically
the Jenkins instance or the ca instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by QA
guys so QA guys would need to provide
some sort of a you know limited access
to developers so that's why I'm creating
a role called developer and I'm adding
this role at a global role level so I
would say add this here and you would
see this developer role that is there
and each of these options you can click
hover over it you would see some sort of
a help on what what are these uh you
know permissions specific to so what I
want is like you know it sounds a little
you know different but I would want to
give very very little permissions for
the developer so from an Administration
perspective I would just want him to
have a read
um kind of a role credentials again I
would just want to view kind of a role I
don't want him to create any agents and
all that stuff that's looks good for me
for a job I would want him to just
possibly uh read I don't want him to
build I don't want him to cancel any
jobs I don't want him to configure any
job I don't even want him to create any
job I would just want him to read few
things I would not give him possibly a
role to the workspace as well I mean I
don't want him to have access to the
workspace I would just want him to read
a job
I'll check you know have read-only
access to the job run
um no I don't want him to give him any
any particular access which will allow
him to run any jobs view configure yeah
possibly create yeah delete I don't want
to read yes definitely and this is the
specific role so what I'm doing I'm just
creating a global role called developer
and I'm giving him very very limited
roles in the sense that I don't want
this developer to be able to run an
agents nor create jobs or build jobs or
cancel jobs or configure jobs at the max
I would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay so I would save
now I've created a rule I still don't
have any users that is there on the
system so let me go ahead and create
some user on the system
that's not here I will say configure
manage and cans manage users
okay let me create a new user
I would call this user as yeah developer
one sounds good
some password
some password that I can remember
okay his name is developer One D at
d.com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which I kind of configure a bit of the
system and developer one is a user that
I have configured so still have not set
any rules for this particular user yet
so I would go to manage and games
I would say
manage and assign rules I would say
assign rules
okay so if you see what I'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular deal I will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that I have already
configured
the role shows up here I would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that I created was
developer one I would add this
particular user and now this particular
user what kind of a role I want him to
have because this is the global rule
that had created so developer I would
assign this developer one to this
particular Global root and I would go
ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges so there you
go I have Jenkins but I don't see a new
item I can't trigger a new job I can't
do anything I see these jobs however I
don't think so I'll be able to start
this job I don't have the permission set
for that the maximum I can do is look at
the job see what was there as a part of
the console output and stuff like that
so this is a limited role that was
created and I added this developer to
that particular role which was a
developer role so that the developers
don't get to configure any of the jobs
because the Jenkins instance is owned by
a cure person he doesn't want to give
developer any administrative rights so
the rights that he set out by creating a
developer role and anybody who is tagged
any user who is tagged as a part of this
developer role would get the same kind
of permissions and these permissions can
be you know fine-grained it can be a
Project Specific permissions as well but
for now I just demonstrated the high
level permission that I had set in let
me quickly log out of this user and get
back as the admin user because I need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created I have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
Jenkins being so popular as I mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or Community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find Jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect Jenkins to an AWS instance or
you want to connect Jenkins to a Docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plugin you can go and
search up if I want to connect Jenkins
to big bucket
white bucket is one of the git servers
has so many plugins that is available
okay so bottom line Jenkins without
plugins is nothing so plugins is the
heart of Jenkins for you to connect or
for in order to connect Jenkins with any
of the containers or any of the other
tool sets you would need the plugins if
you want to connect or you want to build
a repository which has got Java and
Maven you would need to install Maven
and GDK on your Jenkins instance if at
all you're looking for a net build or a
Microsoft build you would need to have
MS build installed on your on your
Jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger Ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server-side web hooks
from GitHub you would need GitHub
specific plugins if you want to connect
Jenkins to AWS you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a Docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the URL which is
publicly reachable you just have a
Docker plugin that is installed on your
Jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect Jenkins build build a job on
Jenkins and push it to sonar Cube and
get sonar Cube to run analysis on that
and get back the results in Jenkins all
of these works very well because of the
plugins now with that let me connect our
Jenkins instance to GitHub I already
have very very simple Java repository up
on my GitHub instance so let me connect
Jenkins to this particular GitHub
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there all right so this is my very
very simple uh you know repository that
is there called hello Java and this is
what is there in the report there is a
hello hello to Java application that is
here or a simple class file that is
there it's got just one line of system
dot out so this is already present on
github.com at this place and this would
be the URL for this Repository
if I pick up this GPS URL this is my
https URL so what I would do is I would
connect my Jenkins instance to go to
GitHub provide my credentials and pull
out this repository which is on the
cloud hosted github.com and get it to my
Jenkins instance and then build this
particular Java file I'm keeping the
source code very very simple it's just
the Java file how do I build my Java
file how do I compile my Java file I
just say Java C and the name of my class
file which is hello.java and how do I
run my Java file I would say Java and
hello
okay so remember I don't need to install
any plugins now because uh what it needs
is a git plugin so if you remember when
we were doing the installation there was
a bunch of recommended plugins so git is
already installed on my system so I
don't need to install it again so let me
put up a new job here it says get job
let it be a freestyle project that's
good for me I would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some Echo kind of jobs
we did not need any integration with any
of the source code systems so now let me
connect this so I'm going to put up a
source code and git would sure because
the plugin is already there SVN performs
any of those additional source code
management tools if at all you would
need just install those plugins and
Jenkins connects wonderfully well to all
these particular Source control tools
okay so I would copy the https URL from
here I would say this is the URL that
I'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password so I'll have to
specify a username
and password all right so I would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password I just save this I say add
and then I would say you know use these
credentials to go to GitHub and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
Jenkins not able to find git or the
git.exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me I'm going to grab this URL what
am I gonna do the step would pull the
source code from the GitHub and then
what would be there as a part of my
build step
because this repository just has a Java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this I would just say
execute Windows batch command and I
would say Java C
Hello dot Java that is the way I would
build my Java core and if I have to run
it I would just say Java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from GitHub
Java that sounds good I would say save
this and let me try to run this
okay if you see there's a lot of you
know it executes git on your behalf it
goes out here it provides my credentials
and says you know it pulls all my
repository and by default it will pull
up the master branch that is there on my
repository and it kind of builds this
whole thing Java C hello to Java and it
runs this project Java hello and there
you see this is the output that is there
and if at all you want to look at the
contents of the repository if you can go
here this is my
workspace of my system hang on this is
not right
okay get job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my GitHub repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the main GitHub repository all right
so this was the same program that was
here and Jenkins on our behalf went over
all the way to GitHub pulled this
repository from there and then you know
it brought it down to my local system on
my Jenkins instance it compiled it and
it ran this particular application
okay now that I've integrated Jenkins
successfully with GitHub for a simple
Java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what I will do is I
have a maven-based web application that
is up there as a repository in my GitHub
so this is the repository that I'm
talking about it's called AMV and web
app it's got It's a maven-based
repository as you would know my one is a
very very simple Java based uh build
tool that will allow you to run various
targets and it will compile it will
based upon the goals that you specify it
can compile it can run some tests and it
can you can build a war file and even
deploy it into some other server for now
what we're going to use Maven is just
for building and creating a package out
of this particular web application it
contains a bunch of things and what is
important is just the index.jsp it just
contains an HTML file that is there as a
part of this web application so from a
perspective of requirements now since
I'm going to connect Jenkins with this
particular repository git we already
have that set we only need two other
things one is Maven because Jenkins will
use Maven so in order to use Maven
Jenkins would have to have a maven
installation that is there on the
Jenkins box and in this case the link is
box is this laptop
and after I have my Maven installed I
also need a tomcat server Tomcat is a
very very simple web server and then you
can freely download I'll let you know
how to quickly uh download and install
the Tomcat all right so download Maven
first
at the various ways in which you can
kind of download this my one there are
zip files
binary zip files and archive files so
what I've done is I've just already
downloaded Maven and if you see I've
unzipped it here so this is the folder
with which I have unzipped my maven so
as you know I'm having again is is one
open source build tool so you'll have to
set in a few configurations and set up
the path so mvn hyphen iPhone version if
I specify this after setting my path my
one should work and if at all I Echo M2
home which is nothing but the variable
environment variable specific to my own
it is always set here so once you unzip
my oven just set this m to home variable
to the directory where you unzip your my
one also just set the path to this
particular directory slash bin because
that is where your Maven executables are
all found
all right so that's with Maven and you
know since I've set the path and the
environment variable Maven is running
perfectly fine on my system I just
verified it okay next one is a tomcat
server
download Apache Tomcat server 8.5 is
what I have on my system
so I'm just gonna show you where to
download this from
this is where you download Tomcat server
and um I already have the server
downloaded again this doesn't need any
installation I just unzip it here and it
kind of has a bin and configuration I
have made some subtle changes in the
configuration first and foremost Tomcat
server also by default runs on port 8080
since we already have our Jenkins server
running on port 8080 we cannot let
Tomcat run on the same port there will
be a port Clash so what I've done I have
configured Tomcat to use a different
port so if I go to this configuration
file here there is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 80 80. I have just
modified it to 8081 so I've changed the
port on which my Tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when Jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcare and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloyed
deployment by Tomcat so for that I need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my Jenkins
instance
so I would go to
tomcatusers.xml file here
I have already created a username called
deployer and the password is deployer
and I've added a role called manager
hyphen script manager hyphen script will
allow programmatic access to the Tomcat
server so this is the role that is there
so using this credentials I will enable
or I'll Empower Jenkins to get into my
Tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required let me just start my Tomcat
server first so I get into my bin folder
I open command prompt here and there's a
startup.bat
pretty fast it just takes a few seconds
yes there you go tomcatel is up and
running now this is running on Port 8081
so let me just check if that looks good
so localhost
okay my Tomcat server is up and running
that sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what I'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
I'm good to use Maven as a part of my
Jenkins so I will put up a simple job
now
I will say job
mbn
web app I call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the URL of Market repository is
uh this guy https URL
okay
because this URL I will use the
credentials the old credential that I
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that I'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after I get this since I said this
is a simple Maven repository I will have
some Maven targets to run
so the simple Target first is let me run
Maven package this creates a war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever I
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see if it
connects well if there's any problem
with my War file or the war file gets
created properly
okay
wonderful so it built a word file and if
you see it all shows you what is the
location where this war file was
generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this war file was successfully
built now I need to grab this particular
War file and then I would need to deploy
it into Tomcat server again I would need
a small plugin to do this because I need
to connect Tomcat with my Jenkins server
let me go ahead and install the plugin
for the container deployment so I will
go to manage plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that I would need I
would install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the Target folder
I will see this web application War file
that is already built so I would need to
configure this plugin to pull up this
war file and deploy it onto the Tomcat
server for deploying onto the Tomcat
server I will use the credentials of the
user that I've created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good I'm going to just
create a packet that's all fine now
add a post build step so after the war
file is built as a part of this package
directive let me use this deployment to
container now this will show up after
you install the plugin so deploy this
one to the container now what is that
you're supposed to specify you're
supposed to specify the what is the
location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it'll pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot War that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the Tomcat server
I will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now I need
to specify what kind of a container that
I'm talking about all right so the
deployment would be for
the stormcat 8.5 is what I need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that I have so this
would be the URL so the credentials yes
I need to add a credential for this
particular server so if you remember I
had created a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that my Tomcat server yes
configuration of this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployed okay so
let me use that credential
I would say I would say add a new
credential Jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
replyer
so I would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the URL of my
Tomcat instance so this is the URL of my
Tomcat instance so take the war file
that is fine found in this particular
folder and then you know context path is
a main web app use the deployer
deployment credentials and get into this
localhost which is there
8081 this is the Tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
I would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it builds successfully built the
war file it is trying to deploy it and
looks like a deployment went ahead
perfectly well so
the context path was mvn web app so if I
type in this
all right if at all I go ahead into my
Tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder you would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the Explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the GitHub server it was built locally
on the Jenkins test and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo I am running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
Tomcat instance was running on some
other server with some other different
IP address all that you got to go and
change is the URL of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that uh you know if you
have a tomcat server which is running on
some other machine that's all fine with
a different IP that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this Jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
Jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using Jenkins and my
own distributed build or Master Slave
configuration in Jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of Jenkins server up and
running all the time and also I told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know gets started on the Jenkins server
it is little heavy on in terms of disk
space and the CPU utilization so which
kind of you know if at all you're in an
organization where in your heavily
reliant on the Jenkins server you don't
want your Jenkins server to go down so
that's wherein you kind of start
Distributing the load that is there on
the Jenkins server so you primarily have
a server which is just a placeholder or
like a master who will take in all the
kind of jobs and what he'll do is based
upon trigger that has happened to the
job or whichever job needs to be built
he if at all he can delegate these jobs
onto some of the machines or some of the
sleeves you know that's a wonderful
thing to have okay use case one use case
two assuming that you know if you have a
Jenkins server that is running on a
Windows box or on a Linux one and if at
all you have a need where you need to
build based upon operating systems you
have multiple build configurations to
support maybe you need to build a
Windows you know Windows based.net kind
of a projects where you would need a
Windows machine to build this particular
project you also have a requirement
where you want to build Linux Linux
based assistance you also have a Mac you
you support some sort of an apps or
something that is built on Mac OS you
would need to build you know Mac based
system as well so how are you going to
support all these needs so that's
wherein a beautiful concept of Master
Slave or you know primary and
delegations or agent and master comes
into play so typically you would have
one Jenkins server who will just you
know configure with all the proper
authorizations users configurations and
everything is set up on this Jenkins
server his job is just delegations he
will listen to some server triggers or
based upon the job that is coming in he
will if there is a very nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control lot of other systems and
these systems may not have a complete or
there's no need to put in a complete
Jenkins installation all that you got to
do is have a very very simple Runner or
sleeve that's a simple jar file that is
run as a low priority thread or a
process Within These systems so with
that you can have a wonderful
distributed build server that can be set
up and in case one of the servers goes
down your master would know that what
went down and kind of delegate the task
to somebody else so this is the kind of
distributed build or the Master Slave
configuration so what I'll do in this
exercise or in this demo is I'll set up
a simple slave but since I don't have
too many machines to kind of play around
what I'll do is I will set up a slave in
in one other folder within my hard drive
so I've got the C drive and D drive my
Jenkins is on my C drive so what I do is
I would just use my e Drive and set up a
very very simple slave out there I'll
just show you how to provision a slave
and how to connect to a slave and how to
delegate a job to that slave let me go
back to my Jenkins master and configure
him to you know talk to an agent so
there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what I'm going to choose is something
called as gnlp Java Network launch
protocol so using this I would ensure
that you know the client and server talk
to each other so for that I need to
ensure that I kind of enable this jnlp
port so let me try to find out where is
that let me try this
okay yes
agents and by default this jnlp agents
thing would be disabled so if you see
here there's a small help on this
so I'm going to use this jnlp which is
nothing but Java Network launch protocol
and you know I'll configure the master
and server to talk to each other using
jnlp so for that I need to enable this
guide so I enable this guy instead of
making the by default the configuration
was disabled so I make him random I make
him you know enabled and I say save this
configuration
all right so now I've configured ours
made a setting for the master so that
the jnlp port is kind of opened up so
let me go ahead and you know create an
agent
so I'll go to manage nodes so if you see
here there's only one master here so let
me provision a new node here so this is
the way you know in which you bring up a
new node you have to configure it on the
server a Jenkins would put in some sort
of security around this particular agent
and let you know how to launch this
particular engine so that he can connect
to a Jenkins master so I would say new
node I would give a name for my node I
would say windows node because both of
these are windows only so that's fine I
just give an identifier saying that
Windows node I would say this is a
permanent agent I would say okay so if
you see the name let me just copy this
name here with the description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system I'll keep the number of executors
as one
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just clarify this
since I have both my
my master is running on my C drive C
drive program files 86 or hang on not
86.
C colon program files
it is indeed 86.
all right Jenkins so this is where my
master is running so I don't want the C
drive what I'll do is I'll use something
called as a drive I have another Drive
in my system but please visualize this
like you know you're running this on a
separate system altogether so I create a
folder here called Jenkins node and this
is where I'm going to place my or I'm
going to provision my slave
and I'm going to run it from here so
this is the directory in which I am
going to provision my slave node so I'm
going to copy this here and that is the
remote root directory of your particular
agent or sleep so I just copy it here
the label you know probably this is fine
for me
and usage how do you want to use this
guide
so I would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs I will only build jobs
with label Expressions that match this
particular node and so this is the label
of this node so in order for somebody to
kind of delegate any task to them
they're allowed to specify this
particular level so imagine this way if
I have a bunch of Windows my system I
name it as Windows star anything that
says from Windows I can give a regular
expression and say that anything that
matches Windows run this particular task
there if I have some MAC machines I name
all these Mac agents as Mac star or
something like that and I can delegate
all tasks you know saying that start
with whatever starts with mac and this
node run the Mac jobs there
so you identify a node using the label
and then delegate the task there all
right so launch method you know we will
use Java web start because we're going
to
we we're going to use jnlp protocol okay
that sounds good directory I think
nothing else is required availability
yes will keep this agent yep online as
much as possible that sounds good all
right let me save this
all right I'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if I click on this node I get a bunch
of commands along with an agent.jar
so this is the agent.jar that has to be
taken down to the other machine or the
slave node and from there I need to run
this along with a small security
credential so let me copy this whole
text here in my notepad
notepad plus plus is good for me
okay I copy this whole
path there I also want to download this
alien.jar
I would say yes
this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by our server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent.jar is found in this sorry
for launching this agent is found this
agent.jar so typically I need to take
this jar file onto the other system
and then kind of run it from there so
I have this 18.jar I copy this or I cut
this I come back to my folder my Jenkins
node I paste it here
okay so now with this provision
agent.jar and I need to use this whole
command Ctrl a control C and then launch
this particular agent so let me bring up
a command from right here and then lost
it so I'm saying in the same folder
where there is agent.jar I'm going to
launch this a particular agent Java
hyphen jar agent.jar jnlp this is the
URL of my server in case the server and
client are on different locations or
different IPS there are specified IP
address all this anyway would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your Jenkins or the slave
node
okay
so something ran and then you know it
says it's connected very well it seems
to Connected very well so let me come
back to my Jenkins instance and see you
know if at all you see earlier this was
not connected now let me refresh this
guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision a Jenkins node and then I
copied all the credentials or the slave
dot jar along with the launch code and
then took it to the other system and
kind of ran it from there since I don't
have another system I've just got a
separate directory in another folder
another drive and I'm launching the
agent from here as long as this
particular agent is up and running or
this command prompt is up and running
the agent would be connected so once I
close this the connection goes down
all right so successfully we have
launched this particular agent now this
would be the home directory of this
Jenkins node or the Jenkins slave so any
task that I'm going to delegate to this
particular slave would all be run here
it will create a workspace right here
all right so good so let me just come
back and let me kind of put up a new
task here I will say that you know
delegate job is good I say freestyle
project I'm going to create a very very
simple job here
I don't want it to connect to gate or
anything like that let me just create a
very very simple
Echo
relegated to the
slave negative two I don't like the word
slave delegated to
agent
put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am I going to ensure that
this particular job runs on the agent or
on the slave that have configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular slave we give a label right
so now I am going to put in a job that
will only match this particular label
so I'm going to say that whatever
matches this you know Windows label run
this job on that particular node so we
have only one node that's matching this
you know Windows node so this job will
be delegated around there so I save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this I just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this it runs
successfully and where is the workspace
the workspace is right inside our
Jenkins node it creates a new workspace
delegate a job it put in here so my old
or the my primary Master job is in SQL
program files under Jenkins and this is
the slave job that was successfully run
very very simple but very very powerful
concept of Master Slave configuration or
distributed built-in Jenkins
okay approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our Jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we backup all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure Hardware crash or a machine
crash we will want to kind of restore
from the existing configuration that we
kind of backed up so one quick way to do
that would be or one dirty way to do
that would be just you know take a
complete backup of a sequel colon
program files colon Jenkins directory
because that's where our whole Jenkins
configuration is present but we would
don't want to do that let's use some
plugins for taking up a backup so let me
go to manage Jenkins
and click on available
and let me search for some back there
are a bunch of backup plugins so I would
recommend one of these plugins that I
specifically use so this is the backup
plugin so let me go ahead and install
this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin so let me come back to my
manage plugins so this plugin is there
so hang on Backup Manager so you will
see this option once you install this
plugin so first time I can you know do a
setup I would say back up this
particular I'll give a folder uh this
folder is pertaining to the folder where
I want to check against backup some data
and I would say the format should be zip
format is good enough let me give a name
or a template or a file name for my you
know backup this is good I want it in
verbose mode I don't want to shut on my
Jenkins or should I shut it down no okay
one thing that you got to remember is
that whenever a backup happens if there
are too many jobs that is running on the
server it can kind of slow down your
Jenkins instance because it's it's in
the process of copying few of those
things and if the files are being
changed at that moment it's a little bit
problematic for Jenkins so typically you
backup your servers only when there is
very less load or typically you try to
you know bring it to a shutdown kind of
a state and then take a backup
all right so I'm going to back up all
these things you know I don't want to
exclude anything else I want the history
I want the artifacts possibly I don't
want this guy I would just say save
and then I would say back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our server but in
case you had too many things to kind of
backup this may take a while so let me
just pause this recording and get back
to you once the backup is complete so
there you go the backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular zip file
so at any instance if at all I kind of
Crash my system for some instance or say
hard disk failure and I bring up a new
instance of Jenkins I can kind of use
the backup plugin for restoring this
particular configurations so how do I do
that I just come back to my managing
canes
come back to backup manager and I'll see
restore Hudson or Jenkins configuration
devops here now devops is basically a
combination of two practices like that
is the development and operations so
development is having their own task of
doing the development and preparing the
source code and operation is responsible
for deploying the source code to a
specific environment whether it's a
production or any you know other
environment so they take care of all
those tasks creating the virtual
machines managing performing the
patching and number of tasks is there
from the operations perspective now
development is something which keeps on
working on the source code there on the
development and they are responsible for
keeping a particular uh product up and
running so they do the performance they
you know they do the coding they do the
uh particular interaction with the
testing to you know validate their
source code a huge number of activities
is actually done by the development team
and they eventually uses a number of
tools like scripting tools coding tools
development tools a lot of tools they
basically use to support their
development because they are perform
forming different kind of programming
they it could be a possibility that more
than one programming language is being
used for your project so that's kind of
you know why the scope is present as
such over here when we talk about the
devops here now from the operations
perspective uh it's basically a team
which is responsible for managing the
workforce right and it's something which
we can use to see that all the daily uh
activities and operations should be
managed effectively and efficient so
that's the main important uh point over
here that whenever we are working with
the operations whenever we are working
on that we should be able to get a kind
of a decent amount of work and decent
amount of activities managed with the
help of operations teams here so
operation teams is pretty much
responsible for keeping the environment
up and running and whatever the
activities and maintenance work we want
to do we will be able to do on that
now devops really helps us to achieve a
lot of Milestones over here now let's
talk about that one by one so very first
one of that is that it helps us to get a
frequent release of deliveries here now
we were doing the releases prior to
devops also but that was not that much
frequent probably people were doing like
every quarter every three months four
months that kind of time duration was
being used by the team to uh deliver the
source code or deliver into a specific
environment but the moment the uh
specific devops comes in the picture the
frequency of this release uh really
increased a lot so some organization in
fact uh trying to do like every month
release twice a month so that's the kind
of frequency which we are getting when
we move on to the devops so that really
helped and you know got efficient with
the introduction of devops here
now second one is the team collaboration
now that has also improved drastically
because earlier the operations and the
development teams were not working in
that collaboration they were like
working involved in their own task but
with the help of devops they really come
along and you know had a very good team
collaborations which really helps them
to increase the overall productivity and
the performance of the product so these
are the prime Milestones which we
achieve with the implementation of
devops as such into our project
uh another one is that it helps to uh
get a kind of a management a better
management here so a effective and
efficient management is what we get with
the help of devops because ultimately
you have redefined your processes you
have implemented certain development
tools so the certain automations and
that really helps you to increase the
overall management of all your unplanned
work so the planning is something which
got really improved with the help of
devops
and faster resolution of issues because
the way you are delivering your source
code to the production environment you
are pretty much doing it into a less
duration of time and when that is
happening definitely there is any kind
of a increase uh in the number of bugs
which is getting a result and there is
another benefit that you know ultimately
the number of bugs which you're getting
in production that drastically reduced
in case of devops so since we are
getting less number of issues and bugs
it's very easy for us to do the
resolutions quite quickly and Implement
into a specific production environment
right so devops today is being
implemented by you know most of the
major organizations whether it's a
financial organization whether it's a
kind of a service organization every
organization is somehow looking forward
for the implementation and the
adaptation of devops because it totally
redefines and automate the whole
development process all together and
whatever the manual efforts we were
putting earlier that is simply all gets
automated with the help of these tools
here so this is something which get
really implemented because of some of
the important uh feature like a cicd
pipeline because cacd pipeline is
responsible for delivering your source
code into reproduction environment in
less duration of time so cicd pipeline
is ultimately the goal which really
helps us to deliver more into the
production environment when we talk
about from this perspective
now let's talk about that what exactly
is a cacd pipeline now when we go into
that part when we go into that
understanding so cicd pipeline is
basically continuous integration and
continuous delivery concept which is
used or which is considered as an
backbone of the overall devops approach
now it's one of the Prime approach which
we Implement when we are going for a
devops implementation for our project so
if I have to go for a divorce
implementation the very first and the
minimum implementation and the
automation which I am looking forward is
actually from the particular cicd
pipelines here so cicd pipelines is
really a wonderful option when we talk
about the devops here
so what exactly is the pipeline term all
about so pipeline is in series of events
that are connected together with each
other it's kind of a sequence of the
various steps like you know typically
when we talk about any kind of
deployment so we have like you know
build process like we compile the source
code which under the artifacts we do the
testing and then we deploy to a specific
environment all these various steps
which we use to do it like manually that
is something which we can do it into a
pipeline so pipeline is nothing but a
sequence of all these steps
interconnected with each other executed
one by one into a particular sequence
now the pipelines is responsible for
performing a variety of tasks like
building up the source code running the
test cases probably the deployment can
also be added up in when we go for the
continuous integration and continuous
delivery there so all these steps are
being done into a sequence definitely
because sequence is very important when
we talk about the pipeline so you need
to talk about the C sequence the same
way in which you are working on the
development and in a typical world the
same thing you will be putting up into a
specific pipeline so that's a very
important aspect to be considered now
let's talk about what is the continuous
integration here now continuous
integration is also you know known as
the CI pretty much you can see that a
lot of tools are actually named as CI
but they are referring to the continuous
integration only so continuous
integration is a practice that
integrates the source code into a shared
repository and it used to automate the
verification of the source code so it
involves a build automations test cases
automation so it also helps us to detect
the issues and the bugs quite easily and
quite faster that's a very early
mechanism which we can do as such if we
want to resolve all these problems now
continuous Integrations does not
eliminate the bugs but yes it definitely
helps them uh you know easily to find
out because we we are talking about
about the automated process we are
talking about the automated test cases
so definitely that is something which
can help us to find out the bugs and
then you know the development can help
on that and they can you know proceed
with those bugs and they can try to
resolve those things one by one so it's
not a kind of automated process which
will eventually remove the bugs bugs is
something which you have to recode and
you have to fix it by following the
development practice but yes it can
really help us to find those bugs quite
easy and help them to remove
now what is the continuous delivery here
so continuous delivery also known as CD
is in kind of a phase in which the
changes are made uh into the code before
the deployment now in this case what
happens that uh it's something which we
are discussing or we are validating that
what exactly we want to deliver it to
the customer so what exactly we are
going ahead or we are moving to the
customer so that's what we typically do
in case of continuous delivery and the
ultimate goal of the pipeline is to make
the deployments that's the end result
because coding is not the only thing you
code the programs you do the development
after that it's all about the
deployments like how you're going to
that to perform the deployment so that
is a really important aspect you want to
go ahead with the deployments that's
when you can go there and that's a real
Beauty about this because it it's in
kind of a way in which we can identify
that the how the deployments can be run
or can be executed as such here
right so the ultimate goal for the
pipeline is nothing but to do the
deployments and to proceed further on
that
right so when both these practices are
placed in together in an order so all
these steps could be referred as in
complete automated process and this
process is known as cicd so when we are
talking about like when we are working
on this automation so in that case what
happens that we are looking forward that
how the automation needs to be done and
since it's in kind of a cicd automation
which we are talking about so it's
nothing but the uh end result would be
like build and deployment automation so
you will be taking care of both the
build and the test case executions and
the deployments as such when we talk
about as such a cacd here
the implementation of ched also enables
the team to do the build and deploys
quite quickly and efficiently because
these are things which is you know
happening automatically so there was no
manual efforts involved and there is no
scope of human error also so we have
frequently seen that while doing the
deployments we may miss some boundaries
or some Miss can be there so that is
something which is you know completely
removed as such when we talk about this
the process makes the teams more agile
productive and the uh confident here
because the automations definitely gives
a kind of a boost to the confidence the
TS links are going to work perfectly
fine and there is no issues as such
present now why exactly Jenkins like
Jenkins is what we typically understand
or we you know uh here and there that
it's in ci2 it's a CD tool so what
exactly is Jenkins all about so Jenkins
is also known as a kind of orchestration
tool it's an automated tool which is
there and the best part is that it's
completely open source yes there are
some particular uh paid or the
Enterprise tools are there like Cloud
bees and all but there is no as such of
offering difference between the cloud
bees and the Jenkins here so Jenkins
isn't kind of Open Source tool which a
lot of organizations pretty much
Implement as itself so even if they
don't want to go
um we have seen in a lot of big
organizations where you know they are
not going for the Enterprise tool like
Cloud bees and all and they are going
for the pretty much you know core
Jenkins software as such here so this
Tool uh makes it easy for the developers
to integrate the changes to the project
that is something which is very
important because it can really help the
teams to say that how the things can be
done and how it can be performed over
there so the tools is very easy for the
developers to integrate and that's the
biggest uh you know benefit which you
are getting when we talk about these
tools as such so Jenkins is a very
important tool to be considered when we
talk about all these automations now
Jenkins achieves continuous integration
with the help of plugins that is also a
kind of another feature or benefit which
we get because there are so many plugins
which is available there as such which
is being used and for example you want
to have an integration with kubernetes
code Docker and all Maybe by default
those plugins are not installed but yes
you have the provisioning that you can
go for the installation of those plugins
and yes those features will start
embedded up and integrated within your
Jenkins so this is the reason this is
the main benefit which we get when we
talk about the Jenkins implementation so
Jenkins uh is you know one of the best
fit which is there for building a cicd
pipeline because of its flexibility uh
open source nature plug-in capabilities
the support for plugins and it's quite
easy to use and it's very simple
straightforward GUI which is there which
can definitely helps us you can you know
easily understand and go through the
Jenkins and you can grab the
understanding and as an end result you
will be able to have a very robust tool
which using which pretty much any kind
of source code or any kind of
programming language you can Implement
cicd whether it's Android it's a not net
it's a Java it's a node.js all the
languages are having the support for the
Jenkins
so let's talk about the cicd pipeline
with the Jenkins here now to automate
the entire development process a CI CD
pipeline is the ultimate you know
solution which we are looking forward to
build such a pipeline Jenkins is our
best solution and best fit which is
available here
so there are pretty much six uh steps
which is involved when we look forward
for any kind of pipeline it's generic
pipeline which we are looking forward
now it may have like uh in other steps
which is available there probably some
additional steps you're doing like some
other plugins you are installing but
these are the basic steps which is there
like a minimum pipeline if you want to
design these are the steps which is
available there now let's see the first
one is that we have the uh required Java
jdk like a jdk to be available on the
system now most of the operating systems
are already available with the GRE like
a Java GRE but the problem with GRE is
that it's only for the build process it
will not be doing the compilation you
can run the artifacts you can run the
jar files you can you know run the
application run the code base but the
compilation requires in Java C or the
Java jdk kit to be installed onto the
system and that's the reason why for
this one we also require the jdk and
certain Linux commands execution
understanding we need to have because we
are going to run some kind of steps some
installation steps and you know process
so that's pretty much required now let's
talk about how do cacd Pipeline with
Jenkins now first of all you have to
download the jdk and that is something
which is installed so after that you can
go for the Jenkins download now
jenkins.io download is a website is the
official websites of Jenkins now the
best part is that there you have support
for different operating systems and
platforms from there you can easily say
that if you want to go for a Java
package like a war file Docker Ubuntu
deviant sentos Fedora Red Hat windows
open Sushi uh FreeBSD ganto Mac
operating system in fact whatever the
different kind of artifacts or different
environment or different uh application
you want to download you will be able to
do that so that's the very first thing
to start upon you download the generic
Java package like a war file then you
have to execute it you have to download
that into a specific folder structure
let's say say that you have you know
created a folder called Jenkins now you
have to go into that Jenkins folder with
the help of CD command and there you you
have to run the command called Java
hyphen jar and the jenkins.bar there so
these are the executables artifacts so
our files can be easily executable jar
files bar files can be easily deployed
so just because with the Java command
you can run them you don't require any
kind of web container or application
container as such so here also you can
see that we are running the Java command
and it runs the applications as such and
once that is done so you can open the
web browser and you can open like
localhost colony80 so Jenkins uses the
ADT Port just like a tomcat Apache so uh
if you know once the deployment is done
installation is done so you can just
open the localhost colony DT now if you
want to get uh the Jenkins up and
running in the browser probably you can
you know go through the public IP
address also there so you can put the
public IP address call in adity and that
can also help you to you know start
accessing the Jenkins application now in
there you will be having an option
called create new jobs so you need to
click on that now once the particular
new job new item new job that's a
different naming conventions which is
available there now all you are going to
do is that you're going to do like you
are proceeding with the creating the
pipeline job so you will be having an
option called pipeline job over there
just select that and provide your custom
name what pipeline name or job name you
want to refer or you want to process
there now once that is available so what
happens that it will be in easy task for
us to see that how exactly we can go
ahead and we can perform on that part so
this can really help us to see that how
a pipeline job can be created and you
know performed on this modifications as
such now when the pipeline is selected
and we can give a particular name that
is this is the name which is available
and then we can say okay as such over
there now you can scroll down and find
the pipeline section so there what
happens that when you go over there and
say that okay this is the way that how
the pipelines are managed and you know
those kind of things so you will scroll
down and find the pipeline section and
go with that pipeline script now when
you select that option there are
different options which is available
like how you want to manage these
pipelines now you are you know have the
direct access also like if you want to
directly create the create a pipeline
script you can do that if you feel that
you want to manage like you want to
retrieve the Jenkins files also code
management tool also can be used there
so you can work on that also so like
this there are so many a variety of
things which is available like which you
can use to work around that how exactly
the pipeline job can be created so
either you can fetch it from the source
code management Tool uh like gets a
version or something like that or you
can directly put the pipeline code as
such over there right now so next thing
is that we can configure an execute a
pipeline job with a direct script so uh
we can one see pipeline is selected so
you can put the particular script like
Jenkins file into your particular GitHub
link so you you may be having like
already a GitHub link so that the where
the Jenkins file is there so you can
make use of that now once you process
the GitHub link so what we can do is
that we can proceed with that and once
the processing is done so you can do the
save and you know you can keep the
changes and you know it will be picking
up the pipelines you know the pipeline
script is added up into the GitHub and
you know you have already specified that
uh let's just go ahead with this Jenkins
file pipeline script from the GitHub
repository and proceed further now once
that is done so what next you can do is
that you can go with the build now
process you click on the bill now and
once that is done so what will happen
that you will be able to see that how
the build process will be done and how
the build will be performed over there
so these are pretty much a kind of a way
so you can click on the console output
you will get all the logs that is
happening in the inside that whatever
the pipeline steps are getting executed
all of them you will be able to get or
you will be able to you know get on that
part there so these are the different
steps which is involved as such and the
sixth one is that you know uh yes
whatever the uh particular uh when you
run the build now you will be able to
see that source code will be uh you know
will be checked out and will be
downloaded before the build and you can
proceed with that part now later on if
you want to change the url of this
GitHub you can configure the job again
the existing job and you can change that
URL GitHub link URL whenever you require
you can also clone this uh job whenever
you go ahead and you work on that and
that's also kind of you know the best
part which is available as such right
and uh then you can have the advanced
settings over there so in there you can
put like your GitHub repository you can
say like okay the GitHub repository is
there so I'm just going to put this URL
and you know with that what will happen
that the settings will be available
there and the Jenkins file will be
downloaded as such and when you run the
build now you will be able to have a lot
of steps like a lot of configurations
going on so uh then the checkout sem so
we can have a declaration like checkout
sem which is there so when is there so
it will check out a specific source code
after that you go to the log and you
will be able to see that each and every
stage which is being built up and
executed as such
okay so now we are going to talk about a
demo here so on the pipeline here so
this is a Jenkins portal now you can see
here that there is an option called
create a job you can either click on the
new item or you can click on the new uh
create a job here now here I'm going to
say like a pipeline
and uh then you know you can select the
pipeline uh job type here now you have
the freestyle pipeline uh GitHub
organization multi-ability Branch
pipeline these are the different options
which is available there but I'm going
to continue with the pipeline here as
such so when I selected the pipeline and
say okay so what will happen that I will
be able to see a configuration page
which is related to the pipeline now
here the very important part is that you
have all the uh General build trigger uh
you know options which is similar to the
freestyle but the build step and the
post build step is completely removed
because of the pipeline introduction now
here you either have the option to put
the pipeline script all together you can
also have some particular example for
example let's talk about some GitHub May
one uh particular uh tool here so you
can see that we have you know got some
steps as such over here and you know
it's pretty much running over there now
you run it it will work smoothly it will
check out some source code but how we
are going to integrate like the version
the Jenkins file into the version
control system because that's the ideal
approach we should be following when we
create a pipeline of a cicad now I'm
going to select a particular pipeline
from a CM here then go with the git here
now in there the Jenkins file is the
name of the file of the pipeline script
and I'm going to put my
repository over here in this one now
this repository is of my gate which is
like having a miven build pipeline which
is available there it's having some
steps related to CI with for the build
and deployments and that's what we can
follow as such over here now in this one
the uh if it is a private repository
definitely you can add on your
credentials but this is a public
repository a personal repository so I
don't have to put any kind of
credentials but you can always add the
credentials with the help of add here
and that can help you to you know set up
whatever the credentials the private
repositories you want to configure now
once you save the configuration here
now what it's going to do is that you
know it's going to give you a particular
page to let you to build now uh if you
want to run if you want to delete the
pipeline if you want to reconfigure the
pipeline all these different options are
available there so we are going to click
on the build now here and when I do that
immediately the pipeline will be
downloaded and will be processed now you
may not be able to get the a complete
stage view as of now because it's still
running so yeah you can see that the
checkout code is done then it's going on
to the build okay that's one of the step
which is there now once the build will
be done so it will continue with the
next steps with the next further steps
there so you can also go to the console
output log here like you can click on
this or you can click on the console
output to check the complete log which
is happening there or in fact you can
also see the stage wise logs also uh
because that is also very important when
you go for the complete logs uh it may
you know uh have a lot of steps involved
and you know a lot of logs will be
available there but if you want to see a
specific log of a specific stage that's
where this comes into the picture and as
you can see that all the different steps
like test cases executions personal Cube
analysis the archive artifacts
deployment and in fact the notification
so all this is a part of a complete
pipeline this whole pipeline is done
here and you know you get a kind of a
stage view it's success over here and
the artifacts is also available to
download so you can download this war
file is a web applications as such over
here so this is what a typical pipeline
looks like that how the automation the
complete automations really looks like
as such over here now this is a very
important aspect because it really helps
us to understand that how the pipelines
can be configured can be done and pretty
much with the same steps you will be
able to automate any kind of pipelines
as such so that was the demo to build a
simple pipeline as such with the Jenkins
and uh pretty much in this one we
understood that how exactly the cicd
pipelines can be configured and we can
use them and we can get hold on that
part now in this one we are going to
talk about that how exactly we can
integrate both the J Maven and the
Jenkins here just to implement the CI
processes over here now what is the
purpose of Jenkins here now Jenkins is
normally a kind of a CI tool which we
use for performing the build automations
and the test cases automation there it's
one of the open source tool which is
available there and one of the most
popular CI tool also available into the
market
now this tool makes it easier for the
developers to integrate the changes to
the project here so we can easily
integrate the changes and whatever the
modifications we want to manage we will
be able to do that with the help of
Jenkins
now Jenkins also achieves The Continuous
integration with the help of couple of
plugins each and every tool which you
want to integrate have its own plugins
which is available there for example you
want to integrate Maven we have a maven
plugin in Jenkins which you can install
you can configure in that case you will
be able to use the maven there now you
can deploy the mavener to build tool
onto the Jenkins server and then you can
prepare or you can configure any number
of Maven jobs in case of Jenkins
so uh what exactly the maven or the
Jenkins really do is the mavenwen
integrates with Jenkins through the
particular plugin so you can able to
automate the pills because for
automation the build you require some
integration with the maven and that
integration is what we are getting from
the maven plugin so in Jenkins you have
to install the maven plugin and once the
plugin is installed so what you can do
is that you can proceed with the
configurations you can proceed with the
setup and this a particular plugin can
help you to build out some of the Java
based projects which is available there
in the git repositories and once that is
done you will be able to go ahead and
you will be able to process a complete
integration of Maven within Jenkins
right so let's see that how we can go
for the integration now I have already
installed the maven onto the Linux
virtual machine which we are using so
using the app utility or using the Yum
utility you can actually download the
Jenkins package and the maven package
onto the server onto the virtual machine
and now I'm going to proceed further
with the plugin installation and the
configuration of a maven project so I
have a GitHub repository which is having
a maven project Maven uh source code and
the mavenized test cases over there so
let's see let's log into the uh Jenkins
and see that how it works
so this is the Jenkins interface which
we have over here now in this one what
we can do is that we can create some
Maven jobs over here and once those jobs
are created we will be able to do a
custom build onto of these Jenkins so
first of all we have to install the uh
particular plugin here
for that we have to go to the manage
shankings in manage Jenkins you have the
manage plugins option there so you have
to click on that now here you will be
having different tabs like updates
available installed Advanced all these
different tabs are available there so
what you can do is that you can click on
the available one when you go to the
available tab so what will happen that
here you can actually put up that what
exactly uh plugin you want to fetch here
so I can put a plugin called maven
now you can see that the very first one
the maven integration tool is available
so I'm going to select that particular
plugin and click on download now and
install after restart
now once that is done so what will
happen that the plugin will be
downloaded but in order to reflect the
changes we have to do a couple of
restart now for that you don't have to
go to the virtual machine you have the
option here itself that will allow you
to do the restart over here when you
click on this button so you check this
option and say that restart Jenkins when
the installation is done so what will
happen that the installation will be
automatically attempted whenever the
particular plugin installation is
completed here so you just have to
refresh the page again and you will be
able to see that the particular Jenkins
is being processed as such here
right so you can see that the screen is
coming up that Jenkins is restarting so
it will take a couple of five to six
seconds to do the restart and the login
screen to come up again over there
you can do the refresh also if you feel
automatically it will be reloaded once
the Jenkins is ready but sometimes we
have to refresh it so that we can get
the screen over there so once the login
is done so my Maven integration is done
so next thing which I will be doing is
that I will be creating a maven related
project so I'm going to put the admin
user
and the password so whatever the user
and password you have created you are
going to put that so that you will be
able to log into the Jenkins portal now
this is the Jenkins which is available
here so all you have to do is that you
have to click on create a new job or new
item so both the option is pretty much
same only
so here you will be able to see a maven
project here so I'm going to select like
maven build that's the name which I'm
going to give here and the maven project
I'm going to select here
and then press ok
now here you will be providing the first
of all the repository from which you
will be checking out the source code now
I can have a discard old builds over
here so if I feel that I want to have
like low rotation so all the previous
builds should be deleted so I'm just
saying that dates to keep a build should
be 10 over here and the number of bills
which I need to keep over here is 20.
you can adjust these settings according
to your requirement but uh over here we
are you know doing a kind of
configurations which we are trying to do
a lot of configurations and settings
same so these are the particular
settings which we are looking forward as
such over here so now we are going to
have the log rotation here so we can
have it like how many days we want to
keep and how many number of bills we
want to keep here so both the values we
are providing over here and then now I'm
going to put the get uh integration here
like the repo URL so I have this
repository here in which I have the Java
source code and some uh particular uh
genuine test cases and all I also have
the particular source code and it's kind
of a maven project so that's what I'm
trying to clone over here with the help
of this plugin so this plugin will
download this repository it will clone
it on to the Jenkins server and then
depending on our integration with mav1
the maven build will be triggered here
so now I'm going to process with the uh
Maven here so you can see here that it's
saying that uh Jenkins needs to know
that where the maven is installed
because that Maven version it needs to
configure it needs to process on that
part so I'll just do the save over here
and or I can click on this tool
configuration so I'll just save or do
the apply click on this tool
configuration here
now here you have the options like where
you can have the jdk installation but
what happens that thing Jenkins is
running there so jdk is automatically
installed so in the tools configuration
you don't have to put the jdk
configuration but at least for the maven
configurations you have to provide that
where exactly the maven is available
there so I'm just saying that maven
three I want to process and the latest
Maven Apache web server I want to
configure here so I just want to have
like I just want to save this settings
so that it will be automatically
download the latest version Apache 3.6.3
version there and that same should be
utilized over here in this case now I'm
just going to the maven Builder
configuration here and click on the
configure part so these git repository
is available here and in the build step
it automatically builds up that uh what
a maven environment you want to select
so you see that previously since I did
not configure my Maven environment so it
was throwing an error but once I have
configured that I have to download it
during the build process or before the
build that utility should be downloaded
so instead of doing the physical
installation of Maven on the server what
I have chosen over here is that I have
selected the particular version like I
have selected that a particular
3.6.3 version should be installed for
the maven purposes over here now once
the that is done I'm going to put the
particular
steps over here you can have it like
clean install you can have clean compile
test clean test or test alone you can
give it's just a part of the setup or
the goals which you want to configure
here it by default says that pom.xml
file is the current one in the current
directory you need to refer you need to
pick on that one what it's up to you
only that how you want to configure and
how you want to process as such this
information so according to your
requirement you can say that okay I'm
just want to go for these particular
goals and you can say like save over
here the particular configuration will
be saved now you can just click on the
build now and you will be able to see
that the first of all the git clone will
happen and then the desired Mi 1
executable will be uh the build tool
will be configured and according to that
it will be processed here so you can see
here that uh the maven is uh getting
downloaded it's getting configured here
and once it's configured because I have
explained over there that 3.6.3 version
I have to select so that specific
version will be configured and will be
picked up over here now even if you
don't have the maven installed on the
physical machine on which the Jenkins is
running still you will be able to do the
processing using this particular
component here so you can see here that
we have some particular test cases
executed and in the end we are able to
get a particular artifices also there
since I did not uh call upon the package
or install goal that's the reason why
the particular artifacts was not
generated War file or jar file whatever
the packaging mode is available at Palm
level but still what happens that my
test cases do gets executed and that's
what I have got over here in this case
so this is a kind of a mechanism where
we feel that how we can configure a git
repository once the git repository is
configured you are going to integrate
the maven plugin in the maven plugin you
are going to configure in the tools
configuration that this and so and so
version I want to configure to run my
build and once that is done after that
you just have to trigger the build and
click on the bill now option and once
that is done you will be able to get a
particular full-fledged build or
compilation happened onto the Jenkins
and this log will give you the complete
details that what are the different
steps which has happened on this one so
what exactly is Jenkins Jenkins is
nothing but a powerful automation server
that is written in Java and it is a web
application which can also be run on any
web server but what makes Jenkins an
ideal choice for a continuous
integration server Jenkins has got
wonderful plugins that allows it to
connect to all kinds of our tools
software development deployment coding
build source code kind of a tools that
is what makes Jenkins very very powerful
from a continuous integration
perspective Jenkins can connect to
various source code servers and it has
also got plugins that allows it to build
deploy test all kinds of software
artifacts so this is what makes Jenkins
an ideal choice for a continuous
integration server but mind you for me
Jenkins is nothing but a very very
powerful automated server at the heart
of it there's a lot of Automation in it
but the powerfulness of Jenkins is more
so because of the tools that it
integrates with and the kind of plugins
that it has got what is continuous
integration from a software development
life cycle assuming that the software
delivery is happening in very small
Sprints maybe three to four weeks is
your delivery life cycle and there are a
bunch of developers who are located in
different locations who are working on
the same code base on the same Branch if
the code check-ins do not happen quickly
as in every day if at all developers
stagger their code check-ins into the
repository finding problems at a later
stage would be very costly for the whole
project early detection of any such
issues would be you know quick to
resolve and would not affect your
delivery schedules so as a part of
continuous integration what is requested
or what is demanded is that every
developer checks in code pretty much you
know every day as long as it doesn't
break the code he checks in code pretty
much regularly and at the end of a day
you have an automated server which kind
of wakes up pulls the latest code so
this code has got the Integrations of
all the code bases that has been checked
in by various developers so it pulls out
the code it builds on a completely
different server that is the CI server
which pulls this code it builds it it's
got all the tools that is required to
compile it build it and test it and
assuming that you got some good
percentage of test case automation
you're also having a most of your
regression test Suites automated if at
all there is a way by which in a couple
of hours time when the team is out or
rather team slipping you have
verification that happens at a very
crucial level and then any breakages
even before the team arrives for the
next day if these are notified to the
whole team members saying an email going
out saying that something got broken
most of the code would be pretty okay
from the perspective of compilation
errors or a build errors it is the
functionality and the regression that
the team is worried about so if these
can be automated test it very very
quickly and very very fast and then any
breakages are detected early during the
day right by the time the next day
people come in they know what is broken
and possibly they know what code uh
check-in broke that particular thing and
they can have a quick stand-up meeting
and then they discuss what broke the
code and able to fix it so this way any
problem that could possibly Arise at a
later point in time if at all they kind
of move to the initial phase of the
project any detection that is early
doesn't really hurt the team so this is
all continuous integration that is about
and Jenkins plays an important role in
being the continuous integration server
because it's got connections to anything
and everything all kinds of tools I mean
and then it is also got various ways on
which triggering the job which is a part
of its automation strategy now that we
know what is continuous integration and
where does Jenkins come into picture
let's look at the rest of the tasks of
our software development life cycle so
if at all I were to visualize the kind
of steps that is involved in delivering
my software possibly The Continuous
integration phase would be somewhere
here where multiple developers are
developing on that and then we have a
little bit of a stable code that is
there that can be kind of moved across
because I want to go ahead with the
particular build that I have and then I
want to migrate that I want to propagate
that across various environments so if
you consider the standard software
delivery approach in the first cycle you
just do some minimal testing and then
you kind of move that to one of the
environments and from there you kick off
more and more tests they could be
integration test they could be
acceptance tests they could be
functionality checked they could be a
stress test they could be a load test
there could be a system integration test
all all kinds of tests that you can
think about and all the way may be
propagating the build across various
environments if all this can be
considered as various steps the workflow
is such that as and when the build moves
across various phases if there's any
failure of course the build propagation
kind of stops everyone gets notified but
if at all everything goes well so your
workflow is progressing well and at the
end of the workflow you eventually have
a code which is pretty much good to
release now mind you I make an
assumption here that most of your test
cases are automated and you have a good
percentage of coverage of your test
cases but if that is not the scenario
then possibly there are some automated
tests or checks that may be required in
between but if the workflow can kind of
accommodate all that as well you know
you can visualize this as the steps that
is required for your software
development or software delivery life
cycle now in Jenkins the way this kind
of translates is that each of these
tasks can be put out as a job so now let
me quickly uh let you know or let me
quickly demo what existed in preach and
kins 2.0 where I could put up a couple
of jobs and I can connect them using the
Upstream Downstream linking mechanism so
if this job one if at all it is a
built-in test cases if at all that
passes successfully job 2 gets triggered
if the job 2 is more about running some
more automated test or possibly
deploying it to environment and then
kicking off some more test cases that
would be job to but if the deployment
fails or if some of the other test cases
fail it would not propagate to the third
shop all right so let me quickly bring
up my Jenkins instance and put up some
sample jobs and tell you how to connect
that or rather how would one connect
that using Jenkins 2.0 or pre-chenkins
2.0 release I have now brought up my
Jenkins instance and in case some of you
don't know how to install Jenkins or you
don't know how to bring up your Jenkins
instance I would strongly recommend that
you watch our previous videos on simple
learn YouTube channel where I've
detailed out this steps that is required
for you to install Jenkins and bring it
up so all right so I've brought up my
Jenkins instance let me put up few of
those jobs now mind you I'm gonna cover
the pre-chenkins 2.0 feature here
alright so let me put up my first job
all right I hope I don't have that job I
say it's a freestyle project
I don't want to change anything I'm
going to put up a very very simple job
here it's in batch command let's say
Echo first job triggered at all right
that's my first job
let me put up my second job
freestyle project
all right that's my second job
all right that's my third job I've got a
very very simple uh Echo statements in
this so it just prints out the system
date and the time in it
all right so I could run these jobs
individually if I want so and let me
just check running my third job so this
is what I get and the console output
third job triggered at date and time
oops
let me fix that
all right so that should fix it
let me check my second job
all right that's my second job all right
so I've got three jobs now if I were to
link them together or if at all I want a
scenario where after the first job is
successful you'll run I would like to
trigger my second job so I would do a
small configuration change in here I
would say after this first job is run I
want to trigger the second job so I have
something called as a post build action
so I can say that triggers some of the
jobs from here so if you see this
publish record deploy all right trigger
trigger trigger trigger let me check the
other one build other projects this is
what I would want to do so after the
first job is done I want to trigger my
second job all right I would say save
this now let me go back to my second job
and then trigger the third job after the
second job is done
all right I will add this post build
build other projects third job again I'm
not really sure if you guys notice this
there is various configurations as to
when exactly do you want to trigger the
other job and the default one is trigger
only if the build is stable so typically
this is the configuration that would
need we definitely don't want the third
job to be triggered in case the second
job fails all right so this is the
combination that I want or this is the
choice that I want and I save this now I
have three of my jobs if you see this
the second job the Upstream job is the
first job so let me check this kind of a
pipeline what I've said here is a very
very simple pipeline so after my first
job gets triggered if I build this guy
right the second job gets triggered
after the build first job is built so if
I click on the second job all right so
the first job was to get the second job
and after the second job it is
triggering the third drop so this is how
first job second job and third job were
kind of linked but it's pretty hard to
visualize this as to you know if I need
to see one holistic picture where after
the first job after the second job after
the third job what was the flow it's not
possible for me to visualize that that's
wherein I install a plugin so let me go
to manage plugins right here I think I
already have it installed for those of
you who don't have it installed you can
go to the available button I mean
available Tab and click on that the
plugin is called delivery pipeline
plugin I already have it installed in
case you don't have it installed you
just go to the available you click on
this and say install without restart
this is the plugin that I want you to
install all right so now we have that
plugin installed so what I want to do is
after the plugin is installed you see
something like this so this is where I
would create a new visualization for the
pipeline that I've created so I would
say my first pipeline or I give a name
for my visualization I would say yes
this Upstream Downstream dependencies
this is exactly what I want and there
are a bunch of settings here I'll not
look at any of that now what I want is I
just want to tell this view that you
know the I can give a name for this I
would give it as simple line and what's
important is that I specify what is the
first job that should be picked up as a
part of this Pipeline and the final job
is optional because it knows that if the
first job is triggering this other jobs
it knows where to end this whole life
cycle so I Define a pipeline any given
name for my component and initialize
that as my I mean I give it the first
job so I say okay and there you go this
is much better this gives you a
beautiful visualization of as to what
happened after the first job second job
was run second job if you click on any
of these that will in fact take me to
the shop all right there is also one
other option which is pretty good option
in my opinion which is about edit view
yes this is where it is enable start of
a new pipeline build let me apply and
let me click OK on this what it gives me
is a way in which I can trigger my whole
pipeline from here so if I click on this
there you see the first job getting
triggered the second job is still
running the green means it's all run
properly and nicely second one is
triggered now the Third third one it's
still running all right so this is the
pipeline that existed prior to Jenkins
2.0 this is pretty decent enough and if
you see there's a one-to-one mapping but
if at all you remember we could go and
add multiple dependencies for the
project that I set in just to give an
example let's have a go to my first job
I can do a configuration here and
Nothing Stops me from triggering
multiple jobs after this by giving me a
comma I can trigger multiple jobs here
in case if I have to run few things
parallely this also gives me that option
to do that but having said that this was
the most primitive way in which the jobs
were kind of visualized and run prior to
Jenkins 2.0 now this feature became such
an important feature the users wanted
more and more complicated because the
pipelines was not a lot complicated it
was not just one job after the other
there were multiple jobs that has to be
run and there is also an introduction of
the Jenkins agents where multiple tasks
could be parallel run on different
agents so they wanted to Club all of
that and the pipeline Lane could have
all the such complicated stuff that's
where in post Jenkins 2.0 or in Jenkins
2.0 Jenkins released a version which has
got the feature of pipeline which can be
written in groovy scripts now groovy is
wonderful scripting language it's very
very powerful anybody can visualize your
pipeline or write your pipeline using
programming language and the point of
everything is code where this whole
group script gets into your source code
repository so instead of putting jobs
here and in case my Jenkins kind of
fails you know there's a crash on my
Jenkins I don't get back these jobs how
do I bring back all these jobs back so
everything is code that's the devops
principle so the pipelines will be
written as scripts that is what I'm
going to do in my next exercise in my
previous example I showed you the crude
way in my opinion of putting up a
Jenkins pipeline but this is what
existed prior to Jenkins 2.0 and now I
have post Jenkins 2.0 in terms of my
version Jenkins version is 2.107 so this
supports something called as a scripted
pipeline wherein you can write your
pipeline in terms of groovy scripts no
need to put up any jobs here and
remember how exactly you put up these
individual jobs you can write a pipeline
script in terms of groovy language Let
me quickly show you a very very simple
and Elementary pipeline that I have this
is what a groovy script would look like
pipeline any agent can run this stages
there are individual stages that is
defined as a subset of these stages so
the first stage is the compile stage and
Stage has got some steps in it you can
have multiple steps in it and once only
after all these steps successfully
complete that's wherein the stage gets
through perfectly with the pass so
there's a compile a stage there's a
junit stage there's a quality gate stage
there's a deploy stage and I'm really
not doing anything much within this
other than echoing you know some text
within each of these stages and what's
interesting is at the end there's
something called as a post which is Sim
similar to or you can kind of equate
that to what would be there in a try
catch kind of a block suppost always
meaning This would run all the time
success only if at all all the steps
that were above in terms of the stages
they were completed successfully without
any failures so typically you would have
your email that is going out here saying
that the build is successful and stuff
like that failure if something went bad
if any of the steps resulted in a
failure this particular block will get
executed unstable whenever any build is
marked unstable if at all only few
things that failed within your test run
and you would want to Mark the build as
unstable a changed this is an
interesting option so this compares the
present run with the previous run and if
there's any change meaning if the
previous run was a failure and the
present run is a success or vice versa
this would get triggered so this is what
a simple pipeline script would look like
so let me copy this Pipeline and let me
put up a simple job for running this
pipeline so let me open up my Jenkins
say a new I would say script pipeline
yeah this is what I want I don't want to
choose a freestyle project this is going
to be a pipeline project so I would say
pipeline and say okay all right this has
got far less options than the other jobs
that we put up so General I don't want
anything here I don't want any build
trigger right so this is where I kind of
I can paste in whatever ad copied
there's also something called as a
pipeline syntax or a syntax generator
this is like a lookup where you can
choose what you want to do and choose
the option that is specific to those
steps and you will get a pipeline
generated or a script generated for you
Jenkins knows that you're not very good
at understanding these pipelines so this
gives you this sandbox kind of an
environment where you can check out
whatever you want to do as a part of
your pipeline and then get the
equivalent groovy script from here let
me look at this in a bit later so for
now I have my pipeline syntax already
copied so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to paste when I copied alright so
this looks good okay I'm not connecting
to any GitHub repository of any of that
I am just running a very very simple
pipeline which has got some steps in it
and it just compiles or rather it just
puts out some messages saying that this
stage completed successfully and stuff
like that so let me save this and let me
try to run this scripted pipeline all
right if you see this you'll see each of
those steps going through and if at all
I look at the console output compile
successfully unit passed all the stages
passed there was a pass the failures
doesn't show up you will see the
messages from our post or the try catch
block that I was mentioning earlier so
this is how one would put up a pipeline
and you also get to see the visualized
view of your pipeline that says which
stage run after which phase how much
time did it take and you can click on
any of these and get into looking at the
logs from that particular pipeline front
that was pretty easy wasn't it now let
me give you another scenario for a
pipeline wherein the source code of my
pipeline would be in a GitHub repository
and I will write scripts to grab this
particular code and run some part of the
code which is there as a part of the
repository so let me look at the
repository that I have I have a
repository out here on the simply learn
GitHub account which is called the
pipeline script and if you see in there
there are a bunch of batch files that
are there so the first batch file would
be a build.batch so there's nothing in
it except that it is just trying to
build a particular project you can
visualize this as individual batch files
which actually contain the scripts for
building running deploying and checking
the quality gate of your particular
project so I have a couple of batch
files that is here and this is on the
GitHub repository so I would need to
write Jenkins job which will log into my
GitHub account and then check out this
particular repository from my account
and then run these batch files as a part
of those individual steps within within
the scripted pipeline so let me check as
to how I could do that
let me put up a new project for this let
me call this scripted pipeline
dead
pipeline from GitHub all right so let
this be a pipeline project that's good
enough for me let me see my scripts all
right now this is where I need to put in
the scripts for pulling out the code
repository from my GitHub server and
running those batch files that are there
as a part of the repository so what I
want to do is I already have the
skeleton of my pipeline that is written
which is very similar to whatever was
the pipeline syntax that I showed you in
the previous step so I just copy this
out here and then paste it here so what
I have here is I've written on the high
level skeleton without really putting in
the actual steps required for checking
out rather or rather running those build
scripts so I've got four steps one is
the git checkout step the bills tab unit
test quality gate and possibly the
deployment all right so I need to put in
the actual scripts that is required for
first checking out the repository from
my GitHub server so this is where I will
make use of this pipeline syntax so as I
mentioned earlier you have a bunch of
help that is available for you to figure
about the actual scripts that is
required for you to write within your
pipeline so what I wanted to do is check
out something from git so it's git
related so search on git and you'll find
this option so I got to specify my git
repository URL and my credentials so let
me look at the repository URL this would
be my repository URL so let me copy this
I'm going to copy the https URL of my
repository and branch is good and one
thing that you got to notice is for now
the repository is anyway a public
repository on GitHub so even though if I
don't specify any credentials that would
work for me still but in case you have a
repository which needs strictly a
username and password to be specified
you can kind of add it out here using
add Jenkins and you can give your
username and password out here but for
now I don't need any of these things so
I'm going to just say git checkout or
rather the URL of my repository and what
we want is the master Branch for now I
have only one branch on my GitHub server
so this is good for me so this is what I
exactly I want to do as a part of the
script so if I click this this is the
script that I need to put in my build
script so I come over here and this is
what will check out the code from my
repository all right so now once I get
my code onto my repository from my
repository rather it will grab those
code all these patch files and get it
onto my Jenkins workspace now I'll have
to run these batch files as a part of
each of my step so let me look at what
would be the syntax so the first one
that I want to run would be my build.bat
all right so I want to run a batch file
all right and what is the name of the
batch file that I want to run I want to
run this build.pat so generate pipeline
script this is all that I want to
specify as a part of my build step and
then unit test I'm going to just change
this to unit I think that's what I have
in my repository okay that is unit and
then deploy and quality Q Capital
quality and this one would be deploy
all right so this piece of code will
actually get into my repository and
check out my source code and grab it and
take it to the Jenkins workspace so from
this workspace since all the files are
there in the root directory of this
workspace it will run these batch files
one after the other all right let me
save this and let me try to run my
pipeline
all right so it runs a lot of things in
the background trying to get the source
code from my repository whoa whoa whoa
that was fast all right so it pulled out
all the source code from my repository
the last commit message from where the
source code was pulled out it was this
create deploy.bat that looks good I'm
saying building checked out project
building the checked out project this is
what I've had in my build.pad if I'm not
mistaken okay building the project
that's what is there with the timestamp
running unit test cases unit dot Pat it
is running unit dot bat and then giving
me the date and time stamp okay so all
these kind of pass and if I go back to
the project I will also see this
beautiful view of how exactly what is
the time that was taken for checking out
the repository running the build.bat
running the unit test cases quality
Gates and all this isn't that pretty
simple now let me modify my previous job
or rather let me put up a new job for
making use of an agent wherein I could
delegate a job to an agent typically
agents can be brought upon any other
remote machines other than where your
primary region can server is running in
case you don't know or you don't know
how to start up this agents I would
strongly recommend that you refer to our
previous Jenkins video on the simply
learn YouTube channel alright so let me
just check the status of my agent for
now yes is offline so let me start this
agent because agent is not running so I
have the agent set up in my SQL and
agents so let me copy the script file
there is a required for starting my
agent let me go to the agents folder
open up a command prompt and let me try
to bring up my agent all right so the
agent is up and running for now I don't
have the luxury of starting my agent on
a different machine so my agent is
running on my the same machine but the
agent's workspace is SQL agent while my
primary Jenkins server is running has
the workspace out here C colon program
files 86 and this is the workspace of my
Jenkins all right I hope you can kind of
differentiate those two all right so now
what I want is I will look at the same
job that I put in earlier or rather
modify that let the steps be the same
but I don't want to run that on my
master server let me try to delegate
that using the script so let me put up
an agent scripted job
all right it will be a pipeline wrap job
I would say okay
and let me copy this was a step that I
had put in for my previous job so agent
NE so what I'm gonna do now is I don't
want this to be running on any other
agent I want this to be running on the
agent whose label is let me check what
is the label of my
agent that is running okay
so this is the name of my agent okay
Windows node so let me just copy that
there all right so with a very subtle
change instead of saying agent any I'm
going to run or rather I'm going to
specify the agent will be running this
job is the one who has got the label as
Windows node so this agent that I
brought on my system has got the name as
Windows node and it is configured to
pick up any job that matches the label
to which any job is kind of delegated so
let me come back to my jobs where is my
scripted agent job
got too many jobs running all right so
this is my agent scripted job that I
left half with room so here in the
pipeline what I'm going to do is is this
is all I'm going to need so the job
Remains the Same git checkout is going
to check out from the same repository I
run the batch files accordingly but this
change is just to ensure that this job
is kind of delegated on the agent
all right so this would be my agent job
let me save this
let me get back to the dashboard and let
me run it from here if you see this you
know the master and agent are both idle
as of now let me try to run this agent
scripted job all right so the agent kind
of kicked in and there was a job that
was delegated to the agent if I look at
what is there in the console outboard
he's pretty much doing whatever was
there as a part of the job but the
interesting thing to note is that this
is the new workspace or rather this is
delegated to the agent and the agent's
workspace is this particular folder so
this is where it's going to get all this
stuff uh run the whole thing and you
know the flow is pretty much the same
the only thing is this whole thing ran
on the agent if I need to check my agent
I would see the workspace out here agent
scripted job if you look at this all the
batch files are here and this is where
the job was kind of delegated to run so
with a very subtle change in in the
scripting I can ensure that the jobs are
kind of delegated onto the agent the
pipeline job specifically as I mentioned
earlier Jenkins provides you two
different ways of writing pipelines
called the scripted and the declarative
the first one that was launched was the
scripted pipeline this is heavily based
on groovy scripting since Jenkins ships
along with the groovy engine so this was
the first script or the first support
for pipeline that was provided by
Jenkins in 2.0 this needs a little bit
of a learning curve since uh groovy is a
wonderful script understanding that may
be a little cumbersome but then once you
kind of Master it you can write really
powerful scripts based on groupie at a
very high level this is what a typical
scripted pipeline would look like
something called as a node node
represents the agent or the actual box
on which your job would be running and
then a bunch of stages are put out with
each of the stage along with the steps
that needs to be covered as the part of
those stages listed one below the other
so all these stages if they run
peacefully then the whole task is kind
of marked as run successfully since
understanding groovy or learning Ruby
was a little tough for many of the
people so this is a new one from Jenkins
wherein it provides you a much simple
and friendly Syntax for writing
pipelines without really needing to
understand or without nearly reading to
learn some groovy scripting again
there's a very subtle change between
these and you there are a lot of lookups
for figuring out what is a better
pipeline for you to kind of write but if
you can figure out the difference or if
you can try to find that particular
piece of code which kind of helps you
out with your pipeline either of the
skips is not really any difference in
writing or kind of delivering your
pipeline using either of these two
methods all right so declario pipeline
is something like this where you have an
agent you can specify the agent label or
if you can say agent any it will pick up
whatever is an available agent and run
the job and then you have something
called the stages stages is nothing but
a collection of stage and Stage could
have multiple steps defined by within
this so if any of the steps in any of
the stage fails then that particular
complete stage and the build is marked
as failure so very subtle difference
between both these two syntax but using
either of these you can write powerful
scripts for your pipeline now let me
come up with an example where I'm going
to at least demo one of the feature
where you could run a master and a slave
job in parallel so let me come up with a
demo for that particular scenario let me
put up a new job for my parallel agent
pipeline let me call this and this would
be a pipeline project
I don't want anything here let me look
at the pipeline script that I have
pipeline agent none stages and there's a
first stage where this would be a kind
of non-parallel stage where there's a
need for you to possibly pull out the
source code from one of the repositories
and possibly unit test it if all the
unit test cases pass then possibly you
want to deploy it to one of the test
environments that would be what would be
there as a part of a non-parallel stage
and then you may have a bunch of tests
that could be run and assuming that you
know you have a Windows node you have a
Linux node you have some other kind of
an operating system based node you could
run these stages in parallel so for just
for demonstration I've just put in two
parallel stages in parallel is the
keyword that you're going to use for
running tests parallely so I would say
parallel stage test on Windows and I'm
going to run this in my windows node
well I could run a bunch of steps that I
want out here and then in the other
stage or other step what I want is I
will run something else on on my master
as long as this parallel keyword is
encountered Jenkins will ensure that
these two stages are run parallely for
now I have both these things running on
my same machine but assuming that these
were running on different boxes you
could kind of visualize it as these two
steps are going to be started
paralleling without really any
dependency on each other and then you
could wait for the test results and then
based upon whether both of these steps
passed or failed if one of them failed
then we could kind of Mark the build
accordingly so let me copy this pretty
pretty simple script let me put this out
here and now let me save this out and I
can try to build this
all right there you go the stage will be
executed first this is a non-paralleled
state that's going to happen then the
Task 1 non-agent task one one master
followed by as I said since I have only
one node or rather one system one with
both these things are running
simultaneously you're not really see a
benefit of this but assuming that you
have couple of boxes on which you have
multiple agents running you will
possibly want to run your selenium test
on the Windows box because selenium
brings up some of those UI which needs a
browser you could possibly need some
regression test that could run on Linux
boxes or Linux agents and then you can
kind of break down your tasks into
multiple things that is running on
multiple systems at the same time and
then collate all the results okay one
final thing all right now I have all my
particular job or rather the steps
required for my pipeline put down in in
terms of the scripts and this is saved
in this particular job that's not a good
or a recommended approach so what I'll
do is I'll copy all of these steps out
here here and then what needs to be done
is actually let's say let me go back to
this repository the most preferred
approach is where you create something
called as a Jenkins file Jenkins file
and paste all the scripts that is
required for your pipeline now this is
in a true sense the devops approach
where I'm going to save this out so if
at all you have a pipeline defined for
your project the best place to kind of
put out your configurations for the
pipeline is within your repository so
this may be a different project that I
was referring to but assuming that you
have your project where you know you
have to Define your pipeline instead of
putting that as a particular job on
Jenkins and fearing that if Jenkins
fails other jobs there's a crash and
then you lose out your job configuration
the best approach is to use a Jenkins
file put all the steps that is required
the tried tested steps that is required
as a part of your Jenkins file and then
you can put out a job that can pull the
source code from here as well as use the
steps that is defined in the jetkins
file so let me end up by putting up
another job which is a true javops kind
of a job so I would say devops
Pipeline and this is a pipeline script
and then I'm not going to say any of
these things I would say the pipeline
script is from the source code
management so my pipeline script is
already defined it is present in SCM so
what is my SVN I mean what is my source
code repository this is my source code
repository where I already have this so
let me copy this URL This is My URL I
don't need any credentials because the
repositories anyway in public repository
that is all that is required I would say
and the scripted file it automatically
picks up Jenkins file all right so let
me save this let me open this
so that's the beauty of devops wherein I
have a pipeline that is defined and
instead of putting the pipeline as a job
because pipeline is nothing but a
configuration the configuration is also
checked into the source code repository
and any changes to this pipeline instead
of putting that modifications in the job
these are all captured as a part of my
repository so the changes are nicely
configured so that you know we know
who's done what change so the first
question you'll be asked about with
Jenkins is explain a Master Slave
architecture of Jenkins so the way that
Jenkins is set up is that the Jenkins
Master will pull code from your remote
git repository such as GitHub and we'll
check that repository every time there
is a code commit it will distribute the
workload of that code and the tests that
need to be applied to that code to all
of the Jenkins slaves and then on
request the Jenkins master and the
slates will then carry out all the
builds and tests to be able to to
produce test reports the next question
you'll be asked is what is a Jenkins
file and simply put a Jenkins file as a
text file that has a definition of the
Jenkins Pipeline and is checked into a
source code repository and this really
allows for three distinct things to
happen one it allows for a code review
and iteration of the pipeline it permits
an audit Trail for that Pipeline and
also provides a single source of troop
for the pipeline which can be viewed and
edited so which of the following
commands runs Jenkins from the command
line is it Java Dash jar jenkins.war
Java Dash War
jenkins.jar Java dot dash jar Jenkins
jar Java Dash War Jenkins dot wall and
the answer is a Java Dash jar
jenkins.war so when working with Jenkins
you're going to be asked what are the
key Concepts and aspects of working with
the Jenkins pipeline and you want to
really hold out your fingers here and go
through four key areas and that is
pipeline node step and stay so pipeline
refers to the use defined model of a CD
continuous delivery pipeline node are
the machines which is which are part of
that Jenkins environment within the
pipeline step is a single task that
tells Jenkins what to do at that
particular point in time and then
finally stage defines a conceptually
distinct subset of tasks performed
through the entire Pipeline and tasks
could be build test and deploy so which
of the following file is used to Define
dependency in Maven and do we have A
build.xml B palm.xml C
dependency.xml or D version dot XML and
the answer is
palm.xml working with Jenkins you're
going to be asked to explain the two
types of pipeline line used in Jenkins
along with the syntax and so a scripted
pipeline is based on groovy script as
the domain-specific language for Jenkins
and there are one or more no blogs that
are used throughout the entire Pipeline
on the left hand side you can actually
see what the actual script would look
like and the right hand side shows what
the actual declaration for each section
of that script would be the second type
of Jenkins pipeline is a declarative
Pipeline and a declarative pipeline
provides a simple and a friendly syntax
to Define what the pipeline should look
like and then you can actually at this
point use an example to actually break
out how blocks are used to define the
work completed in a decorative pipeline
so how do you create a copy and backup
of Jenkins well to create a backup
periodically back up Jenkins to your
Jenkins home directory and then create a
copy of that directory it's really as
simple as that the question you'll be
asked as well is how can you copy
Jenkins from one server to another well
they're essentially there are three ways
to do that one is you can move a job
from one installation of Jenkins to
another by copying the corresponding job
directory the second would be to create
a copy of an existing job directory and
making a clone of that job directory but
with a different name and the third is
to rename an existing job by renaming a
directory so security is fundamental to
all the work that we do within devops
and Jenkins provides the center core to
all the work that gets completed within
a devops environment there are three
ways in which you can apply security to
authenticate users effectively and when
you're asked about this question of
security within Jenkins the three
responses you want to be able to provide
is a Jenkins has its own internal
database that uses secured user data
from and user credentials B is you can
use use a l damp or lightweight
directory access protocol server to be
able to authenticate Jenkins users or C
you can actually configure Jenkins to
authenticate by using such as oauth
which is a more modern method of being
able to authenticate users you're going
to be asked how to deploy a custom build
of a core plugin within Jenkins and
essentially the four steps you want to
go through are first of all copying the
dot HPI plugin file into the Jenkins
home plugins sub directory you want to
remove the plugins development directory
if there is one you want to create an
empty file called
plugin.hpi dot pinned and once you've
completed these three steps restart
Jenkins and your custom build plugin
should be available how can you
temporarily turn off Jenkins security if
the administrative user has locked
themselves out of the admin console this
doesn't happen very often but when it
does it's good to know how you can
actually get into Jenkins and be able to
resolve the problems of authenticating
effectively into the system as an
administrator so when you want to be
able to get into a Jenkins environment
what you want to be able to do is locate
the config file you should see that it's
set to True which allows for security to
be enabled if you then change the user
security setting to false Security will
be disabled allow you to make your
administrative changes and will not be
re-enabled until the next time Jenkins
is restarted so what are the ways in
which a build can be scheduled and run
in Jenkins well there are four ways in
which you can identify the way a build
can be scheduled on running Jenkins the
first is when source code management
commits new code into the repository you
can run Jenkins at that point the second
can be the after the completion of other
builds so maybe you have multiple builds
in your project that are dependent on
each other and when so many other builds
have been executed then you can have
Jenkins run you can schedule build to
run at a specified time so you may have
nightly bills of your code that
illustrate the changes in the solution
you're building and then finally you
also can manually build a environment on
request occasionally you will want to
also restart Jenkins and so it's good
that when a question around how do you
restart Jenkins manually comes up that
you have the answers and there are two
ways in which you can do it one is you
can force a restart without waking into
bills to complete by using the Jenkins
URL that you have for your environment
slash restart or you can allow all
running bills to complete before restart
are required and in which case you would
use the command of the URL for your
Jenkins environment slash safe restart
and with that we have reached the end of
the session on Jenkins full course
should you need any assistance APD
project code GitHub links and other
resources used in this session please
let us know in the comment section below
and our dream of X Plus we'll be more
than happy to resolve all your queries
at the earliest until next time thank
you for watching and stay tuned for more
from Simply
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here